[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
ein tornado kann 600 mal so viel energie
freisetzen wie die hiroshima bombe da
sollte man nicht zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort sein
das sind urgewalten das ist faszinierend
anzusehen
november 2013 illinois ist in höchster
alarmbereitschaft
ein tornado der stärke er vier fegt über
dem us-bundesstaat hinweg mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 300
kilometern pro stunde du siehst dieses
ding auf dich zukommen und bist wie
gelähmt du kannst es kaum bewegen
mein vater ist mit seiner tochter allein
zu haus als ein fast ein kilometer
breiter tornado auf ihn zu schießen
der mann greift zu seinem handy um die
windhose zu filmen
bei dieser tornado warnung gab es
ungefähr 16 minuten vorlauf sobald man
weiß was da kommt muss land schutz
suchen bei einem tornado sollte man
einen geschützten raum im haus mit
vielen mauern und möglichst wenig
fenstern aufsuchen
vater und tochter suchen schutz im
keller während das handy weiter filmt
während sie in völliger dunkelheit
verharren hören sie wieder tornado im
haus wütet wie eine kettensäge
[Musik]
nach 51 ewi scheinenden sekunden trauen
sie sich wieder nach oben um zu sehen
was passiert ist
josi
innerhalb von sekunden ist alles
ausgelöscht was man aufgebaut hat
die auch wirklich
schluss mit seinem sektor ist ob auch
ihr zuhause
existiert nicht mehr ihre straße
zerstört immerhin vater und tochter
haben überlebt
diese leute sind gerade so davon
gekommen
[Musik]
in weniger als einer stunde schlägt der
tornado eine 80 kilometer lange schneise
der zerstörung durch illinois drei
menschen werden getötet
1000 häuser zerstört
[Musik]
ortswechsel in russland wird ein mann
während eines gewitters zu einem nahe
gelegenen kraftwerke rufen seine das
kennzeichnet den moment auf indem er
seinen wagen zurück setzt und der horror
beginnt du setzt zurücklegen tröpfelt
auf deine windschutzscheibe dann fährst
du weiter und stellst fest dass die
regen von der seite kommt
was steht dem mann bevor
wie aus dem nichts schlägt ein tornado
der stärke 11 3 zu mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 2 165
kilometern pro stunde
bush ein tornado fegt direkt über sein
auto im weg
das ist einfach unglaublich
dem fahrer bleibt keine
fluchtmöglichkeit im bruchteil einer
sekunde entscheidet er das auto zu
wenden so dass der wind es nicht von der
seite trifft
[Musik]
du kannst die umrisse des tornados nicht
sehen weil du mittendrin ist alles was
du siehst sind wolken trümmerteile und
staub und plötzlich ist es wieder still
1 11 3 tornado wie dieser hier ist stark
genug um einen kleinwagen in die luft zu
wirbeln doch die entscheidung das heck
des suv es in den störung zu drehen hat
ein umkippen des autos verhindert und
dem fahrer vermutlich das leben gerettet
wer sollte im auto bleiben direkt zum
nächsten kiosk waren und sich alle
lottoscheine kaufen die es dort gibt
dieser typ hat richtig glück gehabt das
zu überleben
doch was wissen wir eigentlich über die
zerstörungskraft von tornados
gerade mal vier sekunden braucht ein
tornado um ein typisches us house zu
zerlegen der wind pfeift über das dach
erzeugt auftrieb und reißt lücken ins
haus die luft wird hinein geblasen wie
in einen ballon und hebt das dach ab die
wand die dem tornado zugewandt ist wird
ein gedrückt während die auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite nach außen
bricht bis die ganze konstruktion
zusammenfällt
wo ist es am gefährlichsten wenn ein
tornado zuschlägt
zwei mitarbeiter einer ölfirma befinden
sich in einem trailerpark als ein hoch
aufragender f2 tornado auf sie zu
schnell
er kommt direkt auf uns zu
möchte man einen tornado wirklich nicht
kommen den kriegen wir voll ab kein
fundament und billiges baumaterial ein
trailer ist wohl der schlechteste ort um
einen tornado zu überstehen wenn das
teil den trailer wird ist der weg
der erwischt
dieser sturm hatte windgeschwindigkeiten
von 190 kilometer pro stunde er könnte
den trailer mit leichtigkeit umher
schleudern in so einer situation hat man
fünf bis zehn sekunden um eine
entscheidung zu fällen wenn überhaupt
deshalb ist die vorhersage so wichtig
damit man rechtzeitig weiß ob in der
umgebung ein tornado entsteht
wo sollen wir hin man muss raus aus der
stadt zum wagen die beiden männer
treffen eine entscheidung über leben und
tod raus aus dem trailer und rein ins
auto
autos haben airbags und seitenairbags
aber der motor muss laufen damit die
airbags deaktiviert sind dann hat man
eine chance
verdammt erhält direkt auf uns zu ich
weiß was
ich will hier weg
überall fliegen trümmerteile um ein
massives kantholz aus irgend einem haus
das du nicht mal kennst fliegt ihr
plötzlich durch die windschutzscheibe
man sie dir das an
dieser kondensation streeter also die
wolke selbst ist weiß aber der wirbel
nimmt alle möglichen arten von dreck auf
der dann um die innere feuchtigkeits
wolke kreist er
bewegt sich nicht von der stelle keine
ahnung in welche richtung ergeht wenn
man einen tornado beobachtet und es
scheint als würde er auf der stelle
verharren kommt er meistens direkt auf
einen zu
wir können diese gewaltigen
wolkenformationen räumlich nur sehr
schlecht erfassen und unser gehirn weiß
nicht was es damit anfangen soll
ich glaube das ist dreck heilige scheiße
ich kugel die fenster hoch die wollten
sind so dicht dass kein licht mehr
durchkommt eine extrem gefährliche
situation
es gibt keine sichere zuflucht der
tornado blockiert den fluchtweg der
männer
doch sie haben glück ihr wagen wird
verschont die bilanz neun menschen
werden verletzt einer davon schwer 15
trailer werden zerstört
der sein nationalpark in utah vier
kletterer machen eine tour es ist
spätsommer doch die wettervorhersage
prophezeit regen und wie schnell der in
einem schmalen canyon zu einer sturzflut
führen kann werden die männer gleich
merken
das wasser strömt in rhede spalte und
ländern in einem sehr trockenen gebiet
ist kann der boden das ganze wasser gar
nicht aufnehmen was alles noch schlimmer
macht
während die kletterer sich von der fast
50 meter hohen klippe abseilen werden
sie fast von den wassermassen
mitgerissen
sie sitzen in der falle in ihrer not
suchen sie schutz unter einem fels
überhand während das wasser in die tiefe
stürzt
uns schützen im moment sind hier sicher
wir kriegen nichts ab wir werden nicht
ertrinken oder weggeschwemmt
bei starkem regen wie hier kommen bis zu
70 mm pro stunde runter da sieht man
nichts mehr
sturzfluten gehören zu den häufigsten
wetterbedingten todesursachen in den usa
wenn das wasser deutlich kälter ist als
die körpertemperatur führt das schnell
zur unterkühlung und schließlich zum tod
schließlich treffen sie eine
entscheidung
sie wollen sich am ehesten durch die
strömung handeln und beten dass sie
halten minuten später haben sie es
tatsächlich auf die andere seite
geschafft
wenn es auch nur das geringste risiko
einer sturzflut gibt setzt man sich
großer gefahr aus schick die vorhersagen
wir wollen euch helfen
kaum zu glauben dass wir das überlebt
haben
ich sehe sie 150 kilometer östlich
ebenfalls in utah sechs stunden nach
heftigen regenfällen treffen sich einige
sturmjäger in einem ausgetrockneten
flussbett nach schon
los
dieses erstaunliche phänomen wird strom
genannt und ist der vorbote einer
sturzflut die
flut hatte genug zeit schlamm gestein
und alles was in ihrem weg war
aufzunehmen bäume oder äste die sie über
viele kilometer mit sich gerissen hat
[Musik]
jedes jahr kommen mehr menschen durch
fluten ums leben als durch tornados
hurricanes oder blitzschläge wer in
einen schutz stromgerät hat so gut wie
keine chance dass die sonne herangehen
sich sogar ein wettrennen mit ihm
liefern und das auch noch filmen ich sag
nur nichts wie weg
denn direkt hinter dieser geröll walze
kommt ein gewaltiger schwall wasser
plötzlich kommt das ganze wasser von
hinten so was kann tödlich enden
so was habe ich noch nie gesehen das ist
ein bisschen schwerer als ein auto
dahinter stecken unvorstellbare kräfte
absolut lebensgefährliche
sturzfluten schlagen innerhalb von
sekunden zu dann sollte man sofort eine
erhöhte stelle suchen denn davor
weglaufen kann man nicht
von mutter geht es jetzt zu den
naturwundern arizona
sturzfluten haben diese 35 meter tiefen
gänge über tausende von jahren hinweg
geschaffen scharfe kanten abgeschliffen
und geschwungenen formen modelliert
nord kanada zum frühlingsbeginn in 2500
metern höhe gibt es keine sturzfluten
doch dieses gelände hält einen ganz
anderen nervenkitzel parat diese extrem
skifahrer wollen sich von der frostigen
mount cap formation in die tiefe stürzen
als adrenalin junkie um auf dem gipfel
mit frischem neuschnee dass es sicher
ziemlich verlockend
doch bei dem schweren frühlings schnee
ist die obere schicht besonders dicht
das risiko von schneebrettlawinen steigt
bei denen große teile der obersten
schneedecke quer zum hang abbrechen
innerhalb von sekunden ist der skifahrer
in größter not
du kannst zu sehen wie risse im schnee
entstehen und sich die
schneebrettlawinen gelöst
und von da an geht es um leben oder tod
der skifahrer stützt 450 meter in die
tiefe mit über 110 kilometern pro stunde
rissen in was eine unglaubliche
geschwindigkeit ist und eine
unglaubliche strecke und das problem ist
dass er nicht auf weichem schnee landet
sondern darunter felsen lauern
der skifahrer ist ein beta 20 unter der
oberfläche gefangen das muss das
schlimmste sein lebendig begraben zu
werden
du hast schnee in der nase und im hals
du kannst kaum atmen und sich nicht
bewegen
das problem ist der sauerstoffmangel man
hat mit sauerstoff und kohlendioxid aus
in dieser blase gibt es aber nur eine
begrenzte menge davon kannst du nicht
rausfällt sauerstoff und immer mehr co2
entsteht
zum glück ist dieser skifahrer mit einer
sogenannten ever lang ausgerüstet einem
speziellen brustgurt der die verbrauchte
atemluft am körper vorbeiführt und
frischen sauerstoff aus dem schnee zieht
nach qualvollen vier minuten und 28
sekunden wird er gerettet
als er unter den schneemassen begraben
wurde hat er einen handschuh verloren
seine begleiter haben diesen handschuh
entdeckt das war der einzige
anhaltspunkt ihn zu finden und
auszugraben
es ist als würde sich der himmel öffnen
und sagen eine chance hast du noch
eine hochzeit im freien erfordert
monatelange planung jedes detail muss
stimmen nur das wetter lässt sich nicht
planen
[Musik]
die ganze woche davor verfolgt man den
wetterbericht
doch wenn die natur in die trickkiste
greift helfen auch keine gebete mehr
[Musik]
ein heftiger sandsturm springt diese
hochzeit in arizona
so muss es sich anfühlen wenn man vor
einem sandstrahler gerät ziemlich
schmerzhaft dieser kleinen körnchen
werden von einem kräftigen wind
angetrieben und pieksen man sieht ein
paar das komplett von einem hub
umschlossen wird
im südwesten der usa schlagen hoops in
den sommermonaten zu
gewitter und regen kommen runter sie
sind sehr heftig und wirbeln eine menge
staub und dreck durch die gegend und
dann entsteht diese gewaltige wolke aus
dreck staub und wind keine gute zeit für
eine hochzeit
diese gigantischen wende aussagen können
bis zu drei kilometer hoch werden und
fast 100 kilometer in der stunde
zurücklegen eine art bub am hochzeitstag
gilt als gutes omen hiermit erkläre ich
sie zu mann und frau glückwunsch sie
dürfen die braut jetzt küssen
wir sollten herausfinden ob die beiden
immer noch zusammen sind
im darauffolgenden jahr wurde dem paar
ein wunderschönes mädchen geboren
doch kommen wir vom sandsturm zum regen
sturm in key largo florida gibt es eine
feuchtfröhliche hochzeit der besonderen
art wir sehen hier ein junges paar die
brautjungfern die trauzeugen alles
teilnehmer dieser strand hochzeit
oh mein gott
sollte jemand etwas gegen diese
verbindung haben bürger jetzt sprechen
[Musik]
muss ja jemand hat gesprochen das war
wohl das zeichen
sie halten einen schirm ich meine alles
in dieser situation schreit doch dann
hat
[Musik]
man sieht den einschlag sieht aus als
würde er ins wasser gehen das war extrem
dicht dran und die sollten da sofort
verschwinden
normalerweise geht man jetzt nach
drinnen und wartet noch 30 minuten nach
dem letzten blitz
nicht so diese hochzeitsgesellschaft
diese leute verdoppeln ihr risiko sogar
und baden während des gewitters
extrem unvorsichtig
es gibt einen grund warum wir uns nicht
mit einem föhn in die badewanne legen
ich bin sprachlos dass die an sowas auch
nur denken können
zeit für eine grundlegende frage
eine interessante statistik 80 prozent
aller todesfälle nach blitzeinschlägen
sind männer ich will jetzt nicht sagen
dass männer zu dickköpfig sind eine
party abzublasen doch genau das sage ich
manchmal ändert sich das leben innerhalb
eines wimpernschlag some laguna beach in
kalifornien ist der große moment für ein
paar gekommen auch das meer gerät bei so
viel emotionen in wallung
ich denke nur holt auch bitte jemand
diesen ringen nicht loslassen
wie konnte der ring im kästchen bleiben
der ring ist sicher allein für dieses
kunststück würde ich ihn heiraten
[Musik]
um das klarzustellen sollte ich mal
heiraten macht mir keinen antrag auf
einem felsen mit wellen drumrum mehr
verlange ich nicht bittet
irgendwie muss ich die sache mit der
hochzeit im freien noch einmal
überdenken vielleicht sollte ich doch
für drinnen planen wie eine clevere
meteorologin das tun würde so wie dieses
paar auch die beiden haben sich das
jawort schließlich in einer kirche
gegeben
falls sich
eine familie ist auf dem rückweg von
einem campingausflug sie bemerkt nicht
dass sich auf ihrem weg südlich des
ortes mountains in idaho ein desaster
zusammenbraut
resino wie nah wir dran sind
okay ganz ruhig ganz ruhig das
buschfeuer breitet sich rasend schnell
aus das 20 jahre alte wohnmobil ist eher
langsam
das kommt über die straße ok bleib ruhig
ganz ruhig
sie fahren etwa 120 und es kommt immer
näher das feuer bewegt sich rasend
schnell da kommt es okay leute haltet
durch das war eine feuerwand die direkt
auf die straße zu heute
es gibt keine andere straße auf der sie
entkommen können
gleich erwischt es uns ich habe angst
80 hektar land brennen lichterloh neben
dem highway die gesamte straße ist in
schwarzem rauch gehüllt
doch was für ein alptraum wir sitzen in
der falle wir sitzen in der falle
ich habe angst das feuer könnte über die
straße springen und weiter brennen und
dann säßen sie in der falle
ich weiß es nicht aber sie brauche ich
tue es für dich okay der vater
entscheidet sich spontan die straße zu
verlassen um vom feuer weg zu fahren
eine weise entscheidung und die einzige
chance sich vor dem flächenbrand zu
retten guckt euch das an wir können hier
weg aber all die anderen autos sind im
feuer gefangen
respekt der vater hat die ruhe weg bei
aller dramatik konzentriert er sich nur
aufs fahren weg vom feuer zu kommen ich
werde über die schienen fahren lasst uns
einen platz suchen wo wir sicher sind
okay vielleicht hierdurch denn sie
warten auf dieser seite des zauns
hatte ich fest auch wenn ein buschfeuer
weit entfernt zu sein scheint an einem
windigen tag können die flammen fast 25
kilometer pro stunde zurücklegen und ein
auto einschließen
viel glück und danke danke
durch das besonnene handeln des vaters
ist diese familie mit dem leben davon
gekommen
was wissen sie über buschfeuer
buschfeuer bilden feuer wolken die zu
niederschlägen führen und neue feuer
durch blitze und abwinde erzeugen
buschfeuer können fast schon ihr eigenes
wetter erzeugen mit eigenen winden von
denen man nicht weiß in welche richtung
sie gehen
[Musik]
vom feuer zu eis
das war fast wie in einem hollywoodfilm
das erstaunliche ist dass das kein
großflächiger schneesturm war 80
kilometer östlich des lake michigan
kommt es plötzlich zu einem leid auch
mehrere fahrzeuge krachten ineinander
innerhalb von sekunden verschlechtert
sich die sicht von mehreren kilometern
auf wenige meter es ist als würde man
direkt in einen schneesturm hineinfahren
sobald man merkt was passiert muss man
sofort seine geschwindigkeit drosseln
bei temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt
sind die straßen spiegelglatt
front radantrieb hinterradantrieb
allradantrieb total egal bei diesem
wetter geht nichts mehr
immer mehr fahrzeuge krachten ineinander
[Musik]
bei diesem wetter muss man einen drei
oder sogar vier mal längeren bremsweg
einrechnen
ist der erste unfall erst passiert wird
eine kettenreaktion ausgelöst
ja
die situation wird noch dramatischer als
ein auto feuer fängt
ein überspringen der funke bringt ein
laster mit 20 tonnen gas zur explosion
der kameramann kommt nur knapp mit dem
leben davon
ich hatte die kamera total vergessen und
bin in einen graben gefahren den
feuerwehrmann der mich da rausgeholt hat
bin ich echt dankbar
11 feuerwehrzüge rücken aus erst nach
drei stunden haben sie den brand
gelöscht
mehr als 190 autos lkw und
sattelschlepper werden bei diesem
massenunfall zerstört 23 menschen werden
verletzt einer davon tödlich diese
gefährlichen bedingungen die
typischerweise im gebiet der großen seen
auftreten entstehen wenn sich kalte luft
über das wärmere wasser der seen bewegt
und dabei ein dichtes wolkenband formt
wie aus dem nichts kommt es dann zu
heftigen schneefällen die sonne scheint
keine schneeflocke weit und breit und
innerhalb von zehn minuten kann man
plötzlich in so eine schneewand geraten
starke winde peitschen durch ein
flusstal im australischen jara
nationalpark für die autofahrer eine
hochbrisante situation
im riesen moment denkt man nur bitte
lieber gott lass keinen baum auf ein
auto fallen und dann
als würden die bäume angreifen und dabei
nicht erwischt zu werden das ist schon
ein kunststück
tus bäume sind flachwurzler zudem sind
diese bäume durch ein kürzeres
buschfeuer geschwächt was die autofahrer
vermutlich nicht wissen die bäume sind
sehr nass und schwer der boden ist
lockerer als sonst und jede böe kann sie
umschmeißen
nicht umsonst wird der australische
optus baum auch witwen macher genannt
der fahrer dieses wagens ahnte dass
etwas passieren würde wenn es sieht aus
als würde er sofort bremsen das hat er
gut hingekriegt
ein fahrer filmt eine unfallstelle
während er darauf wartete dass die
straße wieder frei wird doch plötzlich
merkt er dass er selbst in
schwierigkeiten ist ein sattelschlepper
hinter ihm gerät auf blitzeis
der schiesst direkt hinter ihm lang und
verfehlte nur um wenige millimeter er
rutscht wie auf schmierseife
blitzeis ist für autofahrer extrem
gefährlich denn es kommt wie aus dem
nichts auf der straße bildet es einen
kaum sichtbaren belag aus gefrorenem
wasser
du guckst auf die straße und sie sind
nass aus und wenn es kälter wird und der
regen auf der straße gefriert kann man
den unterschied kaum sehen aber die
strasse ist plötzlich spiegelglatt
es spielt keine rolle wie dick das eis
ist ausschlaggebend ist dass die
oberfläche keinerlei reibung bietet
glücklicherweise haben beide fahrer die
beinahe katastrophe überlebt ich hoffe
dass dieser typ seine familie besonders
fest umarmt hat
in der beta quizfrage geht es um leben
oder tod
wenn sie auf blitzeis treffen sollten
sie folgendes tun beide hände ans
lenkrad und fuß vom gas wenn man erst
mal ins rutschen gekommen ist fuß von
der bremse und nicht gegen lenken
new york city 2 millionen menschen
drängen sich während einer fängst gewinn
day parade durch die straßen der stadt
doch als der wind geschwindigkeiten von
über 65 kilometer pro stunde erreicht
verwandelt sich vorne der dinosaurier in
einen echten alptraum
er zeigt dieser wind in den straßen von
new york als ob man einen schirm in
einem windkanal halten würde
[Musik]
versuchen sie mal etwas festzuhalten
dass mit 4000 hektolitern helium gefüllt
und riesig
das ding unter kontrolle zu halten muss
richtig schwer für die leute gewesen
sein
schließlich wird der ungestüme bar nähe
von einer straßenlaterne auf geschnitzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nicht nur geht es schlecht auch vier
besucher werden verletzt als folge
wurden die
sicherheitslage verbessert wenn der wind
jetzt eine geschwindigkeit von 55
kilometern pro stunde überschreitet
werden die ballons zu boden geholt die
lehre daraus war dass sowas jederzeit
wieder passieren kann und das darf nicht
sein
[Applaus]
von den straßen manhattans zu einem teil
in santa barbara kalifornien in diesem
restaurant direkt an der küste herrscht
hochbetrieb doch ein wintersturm schiebt
große wellen vor sich her
die wellen an der westküste ziehen viele
schaulustige an die winterstürme sind
berüchtigt für ihre hohen bällen guck
dir das an hier kommt eine große
die behörden warnen vor stürmischer see
mit bis zu drei meter siebzig hohen
wellen da kommt sie da konnte
fantastisch dass ich keiner bewegt ich
bin auch erschrocken aber es ist ein
video jetzt kann ich nicht erwischen
heilige scheiße
das ist eine große
oh man ein beängstigender anblick
[Musik]
seit abzuhauen sie hat vollkommen recht
zeit abzuhauen wer weiß ob nicht noch
seine kommt
zum glück wird niemand durch die
umherfliegenden glassplitter verletzt
der keim wird wegen des hohen
wellengangs gesperrt doch am nächsten
tag ist im restaurant wieder alles wie
gehabt
nur wenige monate später in einem vorort
von los angeles herrscht football fieber
ein wundervoller tag alle freuen sich
auf den fußball ich liebe football aber
das einzige das jetzt in fahrt kommt ist
ein unerwarteter und gefährlicher staub
teufel so etwas kann man nicht
vorhersagen das ist eine wirklich
verrückte sache
wie aus dem nichts taucht dieser riesige
staffel auch an staub wirbelt mit
windgeschwindigkeiten zwischen 50 und 65
kilometer pro stunde er zerstört alles
auf seinem weg
staub teufel treten vor allem in
trockenen gebieten auf und sind fast
unsichtbar aber ihr rotierender wirbel
verhält sich wie ein kleiner tornado
stark teufelinnen tornados aber sie
entstehen unter anderen bedingungen sie
brauchen einen tag wie diesen mit viel
sonne aufgeheizten boden und leichtem
bis mäßigem wind
an diesem tag war es eigentlich ziemlich
kalt zumindest für haye wenn sich große
hitze unter kalte luftmassen schiebt
entsteht eine starke zirkulation sowie
hier
vier personen werden durch
umherfliegende trümmerteile leicht
verletzt
aber wissen sie wo solche staub teufeln
wirklich riesige ausmaße annehmen
dieser staub teufel wurde auf dem mars
aufgenommen und ist fast einen kilometer
hoch staub teufel auf dem roten planeten
können sogar 20 kilometer hoch werden
[Musik]
auf dem volksfest indiana state fair
richter abend an 12.000 country fans
warten ungeduldig auf den auftritt der
band sugarland doch sie erwartet etwas
ganz anderes du bist in diesen großen
offenen bereich sie ist die wolken und
fragst dich ich sollte schutz suchen
aber da war ein großes gewitter im
anmarsch das war nur noch eine frage von
minuten
die niederschläge haben die luft
abgekühlt die von dem gewitter dorthin
getrieben wurde
während der sturm sich auf das
messegelände zubewegt kollabiert seine
front und kalte luftmassen strömen
hinaus
diese kalte luft die das gewitter vor
sich herschiebt wird böen front genannt
und kann windgeschwindigkeiten von über
160 kilometern pro stunde erzeugen
man würde niemals auf die idee kommen
dass so etwas schlimmes tatsächlich
passieren kann
der wind legt richtig zu und plötzlich
wird die horizontal gegen diese planen
an der bühne er verwandelt sie
praktischen segel und alles kraft ein
mit fast 100 kilometern pro stunde
peitschte der wind gegen die
bühnenaufbauten und bringt sie komplett
zum einsturz
sieben menschen sterben bei dieser
tragödie
es muss kein tornado sein es muss
überhaupt kein besonderer sturm
eintreten trotzdem kann solch gewaltiger
schaden entstehen die untersuchung
ergibt dass sowohl die bauvorschriften
für die bühnenaufbauten als auch die
notfallpläne unzureichend waren
[Musik]
klingt wie artilleriefeuer jetzt geht's
los das wird ein großer
im kino flops nationalpark in alaska
bestaunen touristen den einsturz eines
gletschers
wenn die natur in aktion tritt wissen
wir nicht wirklich wie wir reagieren
sollen wir sind wie gelähmt
es ist verlockend so nah wie möglich
anzugehen um ein video zu machen und
alles zu sehen
das wegbrechen des eises nennt man das
kalben des gletschers
das ist ein natürlicher prozess
gletscher wachsen jedes jahr im winter
und schrumpfen wieder im sommer
diese wundervolle leicht bläulichen
schimmer ist älteres eis aus ihm ist
sämtlicher sauerstoff gewesen und weil
man keine lufteinschlüsse mehr hat wird
das licht hier anders reflektiert
und dann beginnt die show
das ist unglaublich unglaublich
und plötzlich macht es klick und man
denkt hey vielleicht ist es doch nicht
der sicherste ort hier
der kapitän handelt sofort und dreht weg
von der welle
das war ein kluger zug vom kapitän mit
dem boot abzudrehen als das eis fiel
damit hat er das boot vermutlich
gerettet
es geht los ich glaube es geht los etwa
4000 kilometer entfernt drehte ein
filmteam die fantastische
gletscherlandschaft westgrönland
ein eisbrocken von der größe eines
berges bricht von ilulissat gletscher ab
und stürzt ins meer
es fühlt sich fast lebendig an das
knacken und knarren und das ächzen des
gletschers
das ist ein unfassbar großes stück des
gletschers dass der abbricht und sich
seinen weg ins wasser warnt wie eine
lawine die ins meer stürzt stellen sie
sich vor wie lower manhattan vor ihren
augen zerbröckelt nur dass diese
gletscher zwei oder drei mal so groß
sind wie das höchste gebäude in
manhattan
eine unfassbare menge 15 kilometer lang
und 800 meter breit bricht vom gletscher
ab und ist für immer fort
[Musik]
überall auf der welt schrumpfen die
gletscher mit alarmierender
geschwindigkeit und das ist wirklich
besorgniserregend weil es zeigt wie
schnell eis schmelzen und weg brechen
kann
grönland verliert jedes jahr zig
milliarden tonnen eis eine beängstigende
quote
theoretisch sollte dieser gletscher
jeden dezember dasselbe volumen haben
hat er aber nicht
das ist ein beispiel dafür wie der
klimawandel unsere welt verändert
der petersen gletscher in alaska ist in
100 jahren schätzungsweise eineinhalb
kilometer geschrumpft
diese vorher nachher aufnahmen wurden
über das letzte jahrhundert immer zur
selben jahreszeit von us-geologen
aufgenommen
wenn es um gewaltige wetterphänomene
geht dürfen die great plains in der
mitte der usa nicht fehlen hier entladen
sich die mächtigsten und gefährlichsten
gewitter überhaupt dieses klassische
amboss förmige monster wird als super
zelle bezeichnet als würde man sich
tolle architektur ansehen vergiss europa
die great plains haben super zählen
ich habe meine ganze karriere damit
verbracht die atmosphäre zu studieren
wenn etwas besonderes mit dem wetter
passiert will ich es selbst sehen und
spüren
diese schnelle abfolge von blitzen es
gibt nichts besseres es ist wie eine
lichtshow wie ein feuerwerk
die energie die schönheit die uhr die
zerstörung das alles ist natur und jedes
teil von ihr trägt zum gleichgewicht der
erde bei
das ist fantastisch ich liebe solche
videos sie zeigen wie wundervoll unser
planet wirklich ist